I take Sean Brady via submission I will  take uh I hate this Darius I'll take  gamron  I'll take gamma of your decision I'll  take sugar Shawn O'Malley  I'll take TJ Dillashaw and Charles  Oliveira Charles Oliveira by finish I  don't know what round  I have no idea when he pulls it off I  think he's gonna be down on the  scorecards and he's gonna pull it off  he's gonna have to walk through some  [ __ ] tough tough fire to pull this  off but 25 minutes most dangerous guy to  ever do it knees elbows submissions  punches kicks I'll take my chance with  Charles Oliveira I think Charles lover  gets it done via decision that'd be my  bet [ __ ] parlay Charles wins via you  know finish  um if he goes to judges it's Islam by  landslide